and this week congressman mark meadows
said the House GOP plans on hearing
testimony about the DOJ investigation
into alleged wrongdoing by the Clinton
Foundation joining me now with more is
go pack chairman David Avella Fox News
contributor and former Clinton pollster
Doug Schon and former press secretary
for vice president pence Mark Lauder
all right good evening everyone you know
I find you have to give Rush Limbaugh
his due I mean that that was pretty
funny he's naughty we're gonna talk
about it until we prove there was a
private server in the bathroom but but I
gotta go to you first Doug because
you're the Democrat you're on set right
now is if I could have a problem like
Hillary did she has a problem but
candidly it's not the same problem as
Hillary and I don't think private
servers should be used but I think rush
missed the point it's that the private
server was used in the private address
and classified information as far as we
can tell may well have gone to our
enemies in ways that during Hillary and
that to me is far more serious than
anything that's been alleged anywhere
else
the only alleged by the way David Avella
is simply that Ivanka was you know
appointments with family it's a family
email but I mean what Doug is saying is
accurate I mean that first of all Ivanka
didn't delete any emails did she no in
fact
reports are she actually turned over all
her emails and what we're seeing here
judge is the Democrats are in the
batter's box they are getting ready for
investigation after investigation after
investigation into the Trump
administration with the icing on the
cake being an effort that would be made
to try to impeach President Trump it's
what they campaigned on and here is that
and don't say and people will say this
is hyperbole we know what Nancy Pelosi
is gonna do is speaker she already did
it
she put Henry Waxman in charge of
investigations during the Bush
administration and made every mid-level
staffer that the Bush administration
appoint go get a lawyer to defend
themselves against frivolous lawsuits
when she was the speaker
the house back during the Bush
administration and Mark Lauder I mean
you know Jim Comey made a lot about
intense saying Hillary had no intent to
violate the law even though intent is
required but how do you compare the
intent of Ivanka as it relates to
Hillary situation well well first off
there can be no intent in this respect
is let's remember classified information
does not go over your normal
whitehouse.gov email account there are
special servers that are required for
those so she had to have the intent and
her staff to take it off of those
servers and put it on a private server
Ivanka sending a few e-mails back and
forth about family logistics planning
those kinds of things to government
officials while she was Trent well she
was transitioning into office is not
intent there's no classified information
and every email she sent to a government
staffer while she was transitioning in
was automatically captured by the system
he's the presidential records retention
act in the first place mark that is
exactly the point that people are not
recognizing everything she did is
captured there and if it were classified
he couldn't have gone through I mean
there was no sledgehammer to destroy
devices appear none of that stuff done
but you know David Avella the the thing
that I think is interesting is that Jeff
Sessions announced last year when
there's the whole hoopla about the
Clinton Foundation it took him months to
decide whether there was enough to look
at it and he comes out and he says I'm
gonna have the US Attorney Huber I don't
recall what state he's from look into
the Clinton Foundation I'm sorry Utah
okay so he's from Utah US Attorney and
we haven't heard anything so mark
Meadows the head of the front house
freedom caucus says hey guys what's
going on with this they got a few more
months so they're gonna look into it
what do you think well for those who
watch the AMC documentary on Monica
Lewinsky they'll think both Clinton's
ought to be serving some time in jail
but it was to this investigation let me
say there may be a more production out
of
Meadows if he were to look at all of the
money Tom Styer has put into democratic
organizations to elect people who want
to go be invested all they want to do is
investigate this president and
ultimately try to impeach him let's not
forget what the core of Stiers
grassroots effort is and that's to
impeach the president
so in these final weeks that Meadows is
chairman of the committee and can call
on investigations we ought to be looking
into things like that you know what's
interesting also mark is that Meadows
the house freedom caucus leader is
saying that his committee is also trying
to secure testimony from whistleblowers
who could have had more information
about the Clinton Foundation but do you
think anything will happen in this
Department of Justice I mean there there
is talk by the way that the Clinton
Global Initiative got their 501c3 status
from none other than Lois Lerner well I
do have a lot of hope in this
investigation because of the US attorney
Huber who's leading it is someone of
impeccable credentials and if we've got
whistleblowers let's remember this is
not just about Bleach bit and email
servers and classified information as
important as that is this is Bill
Clinton getting a $500,000 speech from
Russia at the same time uranium one was
going through or the Clinton Foundation
getting 14 and a half a million dollars
in mysterious donations from companies
and groups tied to uranium 1 while
Hillary Clinton was allowing most of our
uranium to be sold to the Russians this
has some serious potential from a
national security perspective it Doug
even you have to agree that the
appearance of pay-for-play you know I've
called the Clinton Foundation and
organized criminal enterprise parading
as a 501 C 3 charity the you know with a
modern way to do that but I think on the
simplest level we oughta find out what
happened what did the investigation show
what have we learned where do things
stand I think we have a right to know as
people what happens if you Hoover comes
out and says you know what I'm the US
Attorney I ain't
you I'm not telling you until my
investigation is over the policies in
the US Attorney's Office are next time
I'd like to know that you'd like to know
is going on and where he stands
we've been greeted by just radio silence
I think we have a right to know as
American citizens where things stand
whatever he wants to share is just fine
by me
okay David Avella you know they say that
Jim Comey when he was the United States
Attorney for the Southern District of
New York coincidence it's unbelievable
was involved in looking at the Clinton
Foundation and then it was abruptly
ended the wrongdoing and self serving of
the Clintons and all of their allies may
very well be Trump judge by this current
crop of Democrats and what they are
going to try to do to President Trump
and what they'll try to do to the courts
and everything every other every other
branch of government they can to bring
in investigations and a pretty
impeachment proceedings which will be
very harmful to our country all right
David Vela and Mark Lauder and Doug show
thank you good to have you all tonight
Happy Thanksgiving